hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking it on you I'm just
checking in on you how are you how's it
go I'm actually doing great
despite the that cough I just did it
wasn't a real cough I just you know I've
I've I've run out of unique ways to say
I'm just checking in on you
I try to do it a little bit differently
and I got nothing left I don't know what
you want from me um anyway so let's get
on let's get on with the podcast here
you know this is just a quick one this
isn't even an official podcast despite
the fact that I have [ __ ] advertising
on it it's not an official one this is
me just poking my head into your little
office it's your little cubicle Edea
living room if you're unemployed or
maybe you're living off a trust yeah
that's a great big shout-out to anybody
just sitting around living off a trust
you know what I'm gonna do today I go
down to the art store get yourself an
easel
you know Oh canvas start Peyton that's
what people do you know when you're like
super [ __ ] rich there's no reason for
you to go outside there's just no
[ __ ] reason I really can't stand when
people judge you no trust fund babies I
feel that's like one of the one of the
biggest issues that this country is
dealing with right now is the harsh
judgement of trust fund babies you know
I mean anybody can be [ __ ] broke and
be like look at that rich [ __ ] just
sitting over there doing nothing what a
waste what a waste of a [ __ ] life you
know let me tell you that you Subway
sandwich eating judgmental [ __ ] let me
ask you this if you were in that
situation what would you be doing cuz I
can tell you I would be doing the exact
same [ __ ] thing and all you [ __ ]
people on your high horse gonna know do
it I could do it you know I'm one of
those people you know people know this
people know me I have to wake up with
the purpose if I don't have a purpose in
life shut the [ __ ] up you have bills
alright that's what you're doing you're
walking out the door and you're chasing
the [ __ ] carrot and someday you're
dreaming you dream that that carrot
not gonna be there you want to be that
easel guy you know look at George Bush
man you ever see a guy enjoying not
being president more than that guy he's
actually good at what he does he's not a
trust-fund baby either by the way I'm
just saying you know he's actually good
at it
just sits there I wonder what he thinks
about just there's no way to be present
when you leave as president you have
dead bodies on your conscience whether
you made the right decision of the wrong
decision at some point you had to shoot
off some missiles because who's kidding
who America is the world's babysitter
okay we know what we know what's best
for you okay and what is best for you is
to do what we say and give us your
natural resources as we pretend to care
about your people okay it's like a
Lifetime movie everybody's acting like
something specials happen and at the end
of the day was wasn't that really just a
bunch of [ __ ] so you could [ __ ] make
money is that what it was I have no idea
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
trust fund babies and I'm sick of the
judgment of who judges a baby first of
all kind of a [ __ ] person you maybe
that's why God didn't give you money you
ever think about that yeah yeah yeah
it's called Karma
isn't that the most overused [ __ ]
expression karma this is my theory on
karma karma gets you unless you unless
you don't give a [ __ ] if you don't give
a [ __ ] if you truly don't give a [ __ ]
you got to add like a level of guilt for
karma to come back and bite you in the
ass but if it's just some [ __ ]
entitled [ __ ] you those people they
scape through life you know you ever see
him
you ever seen entitled [ __ ] just walk
across the room it's like he has those
little kid shoes on then have the wheels
on them you know I take two steps they
just glide across the room they don't
care about breaking hearts they don't
care about evicting people right then
I'll give a [ __ ] who's [ __ ] sewed
their shirt together
that out what is that endangered species
throw it on the grill they don't care
you know is it genius to that just not
giving a [ __ ] you know I mean I'd love
to see one of those people you know in
the afterlife if you have to get if you
actually get judged just to see the
[ __ ] look in their face you know what
I mean and then God at some point would
have to feel some sort of shame being
like well you know at the end of the day
I assembled that you know what I mean
that's what I've never understood about
the judgement it's just like you know
especially these [ __ ] sociopaths as
opposed to the level-headed Saint that I
am these [ __ ] these [ __ ] sociopaths
out there like where did you know
shouldn't you you know shouldn't you be
judging God on that one shouldn't you be
looking up like really you know what you
doing well last night you forgot to put
the I give a [ __ ] about other people
assembly into this one you just [ __ ]
sent it out there I don't know the more
I I vaguely pay attention to all that
space [ __ ] you know I hate people who
are into space by the way they was
talking about you understand and just
just helping you keep looking it's like
yes yeah I get it
i get you know ourselves understand as
we [ __ ] we've seen how gigantic it is
yet we haven't found anything so i still
think this place is pretty amazing it's
fascinating as mars is there's there's
nothing to do there i don't understand
these [ __ ] people that want to go to
mars and live there and it's like and do
what huh living some [ __ ] strip mall
for the rest of your life some Star Trek
looking strip mall [ __ ] drinking Tang
just you can say oh yeah you know that's
your big [ __ ] move that you know
people want to live on Mars that means
they suck at everything else in life
right they got nothing you know you know
what it is you graduate high school you
want to come back someday right smoking
a big cigar going eh you know yeah I was
that guy you used to push around the
playground but you know what I did right
I went I did things I did digs
now I smoke this and I Drive dad and see
that over there that's [ __ ] me it
made it I matter so usually in this day
and age that means you're going to try
to create an app right you're gonna [ __ ]
it I don't know get some sort of you
start a website will you curate videos
and [ __ ] news I don't know what these
[ __ ] Millennials do but I think if
you if you suck at that right
you can't play an instrument and you ego
cannot just handle just being happy with
what you have I think at that point it's
like I I can't just go back to my high
school reunion just being some regular
Joe waking up in the morning putting my
coffee in my thermos going into the
shower and quietly crying was the water
cascades over in my face and my wife
comes walking in going you are righteous
yeah yeah it's just I just sneezed I'm
fine just washing my face referre right
I think at some point either you just
[ __ ] give in and just say hey man you
know being a regular guy is kind of
[ __ ] cool you know or you can't handle
it right this reminds me I've never seen
a a few good men you can't handle the
truth
you know there's too many too much
griten of teeth in that movie that's
right
Iceman I am dangerous right too much of
that [ __ ] so I never watched it you know
which people walking around dressed and
[ __ ] then little navy suits um
anyways if you can't [ __ ] aniline you
got to go back to you high screw you and
you gotta do something and I think at
that point that's when you just say
listen I I got to live on Mars I mean I
can't go back with nothing I got to have
something to say that's like Lance Bass
he couldn't handle that Justin
Timberlake walked away from from NSYNC
right I wanted that
a way whatever the [ __ ] they say that's
not worthy or I all acted like puppets
right he just [ __ ] walked away you
know and you got the one guy the goatee
guy he's got his sense of humor about
himself he makes all these funny
commercials he'll do a thing he doesn't
give a [ __ ] right you got the dreadlock
guy didn't used to bang Jennifer Aniston
or was that the other guy who's some
white guy with dreadlocks used to go out
with Jennifer Aniston you know every one
of those beautiful celebrities always
dates a guy and you always have that
that that really you got that moment
like wow why don't I learn how to write
[ __ ] play the ukulele and wear
flip-flops that's what I had to do
[ __ ] walking around you goddamn man
tits um anyway sorry and I think Lance
couldn't handle it he's just like what
the [ __ ] you know so then I'll next
thing you know he's signing up to go out
in space just somehow try you I'll do
would you put your put out future sexy
songs huh
wait wait wait right went went went went
man man I'm going to outer space
what Oh what is it about wearing your
pajamas in the middle of the day that
just it just [ __ ] opens your mind up
you know what I mean
I swear to God there is no free of
feeling that being a white male
heterosexual still in your pajamas at 11
o'clock in the morning on a weekday on a
weekday and you know what cuz i'm a
liberal [ __ ] i want everyone to
experience that you know all the people
in the philippines
um anyways uh i'm actually i'm in a
giddy mood because i did something
yesterday that scared the living [ __ ]
out of me and i didn't die which is oh
you know obviously because i'm doing
this podcast so you know i hadn't flown
a helicopter since like october until
this month and i flew for the first time
and i could not believe how [ __ ]
rusty i was how much [ __ ] you forget
you're like what oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
that's right you know turn a base turn
it final i didn't even slow down
I was so busy trying to keep the [ __ ]
pad between the compass you know and the
dashboard day I can't even what the [ __ ]
he called the control panel that I
forgot I was still doing like 65 nuts
and I'm I [ __ ] went right by it and
to slam on the brakes right so but you
know I flew around shell kick off the
rust he's coming around coming around
you know so I went I I went again
yesterday and I went up with my
instructor and he was like so what do
you want to do I said all right let's do
the patterns let's fly the traffic
pattern let's do some autos that's where
they simulate uh main rotor failure
that's the big fan above your head like
what if all of a sudden the engine cuts
up you know um and then those kicks left
what do you do you slam the collective
down you add right pedal right trim air
speed rpm here come the RPMs coming up
you pull the collective up you catch the
[ __ ] things you pick out your spot so
we were doing those and at some point I
was just like I [ __ ] this um I have to
fly this thing by myself or solo as they
say in the business but I'm just a
novice so I said alright because well
okay we did a couple those what do you
want to do now I said all right
can can you just step out and let me
just fly this thing around one time by
myself just to do it again and he goes
yeah absolutely so he steps out it up at
to that point it had been a great day
you know not a lot of traffic over there
everything's [ __ ] fine so he gets out
roll it back up you know lights are out
rpms are in the green gauges roll green
carburetor heats up I [ __ ] lift up
light on the skids bring it up boom
holding a hover here we go
here we go cyclic wait for it wait for
it let's wait in the [ __ ] thing you
know [ __ ] palms are sweating you know
there's always that done I can't believe
I actually [ __ ] know how to do this
thing right
so immediately does a [ __ ] crosswind
so I'm looking at the wind sock about
you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't fight it left
pedal now I'm facing the wind so
everything's fine and next thing you
know like [ __ ] like three JetBlue's I
taken off at Southwest is landing you
know I made my call and the guys like
you know whatever [ __ ] six
Hotels standby standby means shut the
[ __ ] up I always forget that because
then I always go six tricks to hotel
standing by
so I'm [ __ ] sitting there I felt like
I was in a hover for 20 minutes what I
really wanted to have happen it was just
like one of those things so it's like
alright [ __ ] this up feelin this rolled
out have him step out I [ __ ] roll
back up lift it off ask for clearance he
gives it to me and I just take it for a
lap around the airport that's all I
wanted to do so now I'm [ __ ] sit in
this hover just going Jesus Christ now
I'm thinking what the [ __ ] am i doing so
finally he called ya guy [ __ ] go six
Richter hotel left close traffic of
clear for takeoff clear for takeoff six
victor hotel and then I [ __ ] you know
took off brought it around and when I
was turning crosswind you know I'm
looking for traffic to join the downwind
make sure I don't have any problems I
was actually thinking like you know last
night I did stand-up dressed his Steven
Adler at the goddamn comedy gym I tried
out a new [ __ ] bit about blow-up
dolls that was killing so hard I looked
over and Josh Adam Myers was [ __ ]
dying laughing on the side of the stage
suit so as much as you make people laugh
when you look over you see a fellow
comedian dying laugh and you know you're
on to something so then I went back and
I got to play rhino sore
dressed as Steven Adler the sound guy
now I would have dressed up as Matt
camera but he's just you know he doesn't
have any unique facial hair he's got
that sort of that Luke Skywalker haircut
I just want to look like me with a
stupid wig on you know uhm and then I
got to play the encore Paradise City and
I was thinking I [ __ ] did that I did
stand up and play drums live last night
and right now I am flying a helicopter
by myself and I flunked so much [ __ ] in
high school
terrible at math [ __ ] flunked French
all of that [ __ ] was a great feeling
and I was like oh yeah that's right I'm
flying a helicopter so I get to the
downwind
you know
where'd you go across 3-0 you bring your
[ __ ] carburetor heat up see if your
[ __ ] carburetor doesn't freeze over
and the engine doesn't cut out as you're
slowing down came around still pulling
power kept my 60 knots as I turned the
[ __ ] bass in the file
okay righted landed set the thing down
nicely and uh that my instructor came
back in and guess you know plug his
headphones in he goes he goes out of
that field I said I you know I said it
was like riding a bike except you could
kill yourself he started laughing and
what I found with instructors is they're
all badass guys every one of them checks
they're all [ __ ] badasses you know
but the second you admit that you're
actually scared they always laugh and
then they usually tell you a story how
[ __ ] nervous that they were but if
you're some [ __ ] cocky [ __ ] um you
don't want to do that because then what
they're gonna do is they're gonna chop
throttle on you as you [ __ ] doing some
say yeah I don't need that even though
it's good training I've never had
anybody do that to me but anyway so I
did it and it made me feel [ __ ]
amazing man just like the sickest
goddamn feeling and I swear to God all I
need to do is make like another forty
million dollars and I think I could
actually afford to truly engage in that
hobby I in LA it's just super expensive
I think if you live more in the middle
of nowhere the big [ __ ] thing is like
just storing the goddamn whatever you
get the plane of the helicopter I don't
know if anybody knows like a cheap way
to do it
I would absolutely absolutely do it but
until then I'm just treating it like the
way I treat cars like I just go on the
road you know I go to budget and then
that's it I just whatever [ __ ] car
they give me I get it I gotta be honest
with you that's the one thing that bugs
me about renting helicopters it every
time you [ __ ] go in there something's
a little different you know just be nice
to know your [ __ ] tail number not
have to [ __ ] constantly be looking or
the control panel know where everything
is know how everything works every radio
seems to be a little bit different it's
just like a [ __ ] it's just that extra
thing you got to like deal with it
wish I didn't in I'd love to just buy
one of those [ __ ] r22 you know
they're fun is help
they're just a little [ __ ] two-seater
right and you're really flying it it's
like if you had a car that just had drum
brakes and no power steering like you
really [ __ ] you know are holding up
this is just what I've heard from other
pilots cuz I've never flown anything
fancy nothing fancy like um but I really
[ __ ] enjoyed it and just even doing
that I mean that how long it takes to
fly the pattern um I mean that couldn't
have been more than like felt like 90
seconds it probably maybe was a little
bit longer I don't know but uh I don't
know it's just [ __ ] definitely left
the place yesterday you know that's one
of those things where you did something
great you're driving away and you get
the window down just driving right going
so anyways you guys been watching the
playoffs I'll tell you four first round
playoffs I tell you the series I'm
watching obviously and I'll say I'll
tell you again I'm just gonna keep
saying I'll tell you I'll tell you I'm
watching those Celtics and the Bulls
Celtics are now up three games to two
after being down Oh - after looking like
we had no [ __ ] answers right and
which is why my nod for MVP of the
series is Rondo without a doubt because
the second he went down the series just
completely changed and I thought all of
the Bulls had us figured out but
evidently it was Rondo he knew what the
[ __ ] was going on I'm giving him full
[ __ ] credit because it's just it's
been a Tale of Two Cities
you know they look like they were going
to sweep us and now it looks like we're
going to run the table on them however
however I think Rondo is coming back
he took his cast off his suits have long
sleeves again and I can't wait to watch
Game six I want to see like is this guy
is good is it appears in this in this
series and last night admittedly the
officiating was a little subpar
and it definitely went in the Celtics
favor and I loved when Lopez was
applauding the [ __ ] refs sometimes
it's worth getting a [ __ ] technical I
love that guy man
that guy comes out every night wants to
play he's a little [ __ ] weird he's on
his own vibe he just I really liked that
guy I love when he [ __ ] started
clapping it's like my favorite thing and
then they go to I think it actually
worked because then we went down they
called the ticky tack foul on the other
end and you saw Dwayne Wade was whatever
the Celtics said to him I think it might
have been Isiah he just started smiling
and laughing I swear to god man I just
think the NBA is so [ __ ] controlled I
really do just for the simple fact that
you can do it I've said this a zillion
times there is no easier game to control
or fix than basketball because it's the
only [ __ ] game where you can sit down
as a ref you can take people out of the
game you know I mean I guess all the
games you can eject somebody but they
you know in baseball football hockey you
really have to do something you just
can't point at a guy and be like hey go
sit on the [ __ ] bench but guess you
can in hockey right I don't know you
know what that's what else things what
you think you have a good theory and
then you [ __ ] explore all the options
you're like well maybe he doesn't work
whatever no you only sit him down for
like [ __ ] two minutes and they come
back out and it's not like well [ __ ]
Wayne Gretzky's got three penalties two
more and he's out of the game right hey
you know back on track with my theory
there you go you can't sit Tom Brady
down all you got it like this is what
kills me about basketball I don't give a
[ __ ] how many points you're up you're up
like 20 points like I this game's a rep
there's one quarter ago you know most
teams are lucky if they score like 27
and a quarter that's like a [ __ ]
great quarter we're up by 20 all we
really need to do is score eight points
and we're fine and the next thing you
know it's just like the [ __ ]
jerk-offs are on a 27 to run every
[ __ ] time that whole thing it's a
game of runs I don't think it is I think
it's a game
of [ __ ] ratings and if a team gets up
too high they just start [ __ ] call
calling files together to add it's
stupid it's a stupid [ __ ] theory but
it doesn't it just appears that way
maybe it is the nature of the game
that nobody can just blow somebody out
they always come back like I would say
like 85% of the time of course I didn't
do any research but you seem like 85% of
time you [ __ ] go you go up like 30
points in the first half you know
somehow by the end of the game one away
what else X what of the boat
unbelievable improbable comeback since
last night's [ __ ] slew of NBA games
it did the exact same thing
um anyways I don't wanna talk about all
I'm saying is that I think Rondo really
showed I mean just I mean it's [ __ ]
unbelievable like how much the series
change one guy is gone and the whole
thing turns around so I'm excited to
watch Game six even if they win I mean I
like seeing greatness I don't give a
[ __ ] I mean I hope it's on my team but
if it isn't that I can't like I can't
just sit back and appreciate it right I
try to be a good guy for right now I
don't know why I have this [ __ ] this
pillow that wraps around you this little
half circle pillow you know when you
have a baby abuse it's perfect you set
them down you give them their bottle of
Jack you know and then that's it you
know but if you try to do it with
regular pillows it doesn't work but for
some reason I have it around me right
now that I don't know feels right
like I don't wait to have a kid to buy
one of these [ __ ] semicircle pillows
all right what else that I want to talk
about I've been watching you know I've
been watching the hockey okay
gotten over the fact that my Bruins have
been knocked out by the quietest fan
based team in the league right the team
that cheering forgot until April then
Ulsan they all show up like they give a
[ __ ] oh man that was [ __ ] high
watching that anyways um the Predators
are looking great but I still think you
know if I already talked about this I
started this podcast twice I forget if I
brought this [ __ ] up I still I'm still
going with the Penguins I think the
Penguins repeat
and I missed Anaheim Edmonton I bet
that's a great [ __ ] series too
it's so crazy they're already down to
just two series in each conference so I
have to make sure that I'm watching for
those people last week you like hey how
come you didn't talk about MotoGP the
race in Austin you know what I didn't
see it and then I realized I recorded it
and this is what you learned if you're
new to MotoGP and you go to record the
race and you got to [ __ ] do it it
might it might be better than Formula
One just because of the sheer amount of
like passing in lead changes and all
that it's [ __ ] insane
and then the fact you just watch these
guys falling off motorcycles I watched
one of the races um well let me explain
first you're going to go to record it if
you novice like me you go to record it
and you'll be watching like the first
race and it will say moto two and
they're on these little skinny bicycle
tires you're like those don't look like
the [ __ ] you know those badass bikes
that I saw what's going on here then
there's moto three and you're like what
is the real one
who is that Rossi Valentino Rossi guy
whatever [ __ ] his name is Mike and the
mechanics whatever that other guy's name
is I don't know any [ __ ] names yet so
there's three different classes this is
what I learned all right on
MotoGP as they say and there's moto two
there's moto three and there's MotoGP
and that's basically like being in
double-a triple-a and then being in the
majors now for whatever reason moto
three is the lowest level so I guess
they go in three two one
I guess that's how they do it and they
don't say one they just say GP which I
believe stands for Grand Prix I don't
[ __ ] up so motor three is 250cc
according to this thing on reddit here
to 250 cc bike you know so that's
basically cubic centimeters so it's a
smaller engine it's not as fast you know
it's still fast as [ __ ] the way they're
doing it but you know that's the one
like okay all right there grasshopper
well we'll you know we'll see how you do
at this level and then if you succeed at
that level then they move you up to moto
2 which is six hundred CCS
evidently four strokes and all the
engines are made by Honda which I find
interesting so hot they're all Honda
base everybody's working with the exact
same [ __ ] that's probably so they can
truly get an idea of who who is the best
rider who is going to get called up to
the show MotoGP and according to this
person a lot of times in moto moto 2 the
race is better because they all just
have basically the exact same engine so
this guy was saying you could throw you
can usually can throw a blanket over the
top three people in that race and then
the big show is MotoGP which is a
thousand CCS and those things are just
[ __ ] Rockets and I watched this whole
thing on how they building their
hand-built it's how much those
motorcycles cost apiece take a wild
guess like it for some reason you went
down they said hey you want to take it
for a lap but if you [ __ ] trash this
thing you got to pay for it okay
and they give you that [ __ ] suit with
the airbag and fortunately you don't
hide it you slide off the bike and you
get up me like [ __ ] what's that gonna
cost me I would have thought anywhere
between a hundred and two hundred fifty
grand you know and I understand that
it's a [ __ ] racing bike and all that
but you know their little ass things you
don't I mean you go to do a build on a
car there's like [ __ ] people working
on it on the other side you can't even
see him a motorcycle I mean it's it's
right there everything is right [ __ ]
there
you and another guy can lift up the
engine [ __ ] is small if those like 100
100 to 250 grams what I would have
guessed 375 tops right this is like I'm
at the showcase showdown on The Price is
Right and I horrific alee underbid is
what happens those bikes cost two
million dollars each two million dollars
each they're handmade all this space-age
stuff I watched this whole thing on how
they built them the gas tank is actually
underneath the seat what's where the gas
tank usually is is the fuel injector
there's an airport right in front of
that right with a [ __ ] front light
usually I just want to i watch the whole
goddamn thing was absolutely fascinating
and I'm totally in on that sport
watching that sport and I'm watching the
f1 I don't know when the next race is
but if you want to watch dude well I
think was the Moto 2 race the last one
this [ __ ] guy came out of a turn his
back end started fishtailing and he went
like right up and over the handlebars
doing I don't know how fast I don't I
don't get how they get up cuz he he'd
landed on like his foot he limped for a
second and then he just kind of just
shakes it off to like a said foot
problems said foot problems in the pit
I'd imagine he'd had everything problems
you fall off a bike you know it's funny
when I was thinking about getting a
motorcycle out here the stupidest thing
you could ever do you know riding a
[ __ ] motorcycle I know a lot of guys
who just [ __ ] flew a helicopter it's
whit's way safer way safer there's
nobody up there I was actually driving
back I was did um Marc Maron's podcast
promoting season 2 of efforts for family
I don't know when that's coming out and
thank you to Marc Maron forget me on his
podcast had a great time we talked about
anger meditation we talked music and we
helped promote any help me promote the
show and I was on my way back it was the
middle of the day and all of a sudden
there was just all this horrific traffic
and this big [ __ ] accident this this
truck had jumped the medium stripped
down off the guy meeting strip I don't
the guy [ __ ] fell asleep or whatever
about ten people went to the hospital
one person died and a dog died you know
so I don't know I just think the highway
is way way way more dangerous I said it
before you're flying in formation
it's like you're in the [ __ ] Blue
Angels everybody's doing 80 miles an
hour there's no radio contact nobody
knows where anybody's [ __ ] going
there's people texting there's people on
meds you have no idea and then forget it
and then right on the other side is
another group of [ __ ] people
you know there's never-ending parade of
[ __ ] people flying on the other side
you don't know what they're going to do
that [ __ ] guy was driving a truck
fell asleep had a heart attack whatever
the [ __ ] he did jump the meeting strip
went right up and over into oncoming
[ __ ] traffic it like it was like 12
in the afternoon you look it up it's on
was on
five right near Colorado Boulevard um so
anyway so I was thinking about getting a
motorcycle when I was I was looking up
those MotoGP suits which are like 2,500
bucks a whack but they got a little
airbag in them and I'm like well that's
what the [ __ ] I would want yo be
hilarious to buy one of those in there
buy like a [ __ ] Harley Davidson and
just look like the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever you just ride that thing
and somebody cuts in front of you you
just late but there's another thing too
these on those when they're racing you
can lay it down and slide and [ __ ]
all that stuff and you're fine you're
fine it's not like you can slide into
oncoming traffic and there's a good
goddamn garbage truck coming at you I
don't know but I miss ride motorcycles
so I'm thinking uh I'm eating there's
just nothing safe about them I was
thinking all right well I'll just get a
dirt bike I won't go over jumps or
anything I'll just ride some trails but
then ever you have any like [ __ ] I
don't know seems like every six weeks
you hear a story about somebody riding
on a trail choosing a mountain bike
though but if you're riding like a dirt
bike at some mountain line ends up like
bouncing on your back but you got the
helmet on I don't know I don't you know
what this podcast was going great it
just went off the rails somewhere I I
don't really know where let's let's do a
little bit uh advertising indogene Oh in
the sting wreath the Gordon Sumner read
it don't chide talk about how every man
looks better in a suit you know when I'm
checking out guys at the the outdoor
mall I'm like you know I'm really
attracted to that guy but he's just
wearing an Izod you know with some
corduroys that's not my oh now look at
that fella wearing this suit now there's
something I could take home to my
parents that's it everybody
if you're sick of gay men not giving you
the [ __ ] once-over
or maybe rolling their eyes you ever
think that maybe it's not your [ __ ]
love handles maybe it's the fact that
you don't have on a shirt a tie in a
sport coat to cover up all the mistakes
you've made with your nutrition over the
last 40 years
thank God this
indogene Oh is making it easy to get a
perfectly tailored suit and an
incredible price you can choose from
hundreds of top quality fabrics and
personalize your suit just the way you
want it whether it's for work a wedding
or another special occasion here is how
it [ __ ] works visit a showroom or
shop online comm pick your fabric choose
your customizations from lapels depletes
to jacket linings and more submit your
measurements place your order and wait
for it to arrive in just a few weeks
then they'll sell all this your
measurements and all that she'll sell
all of that [ __ ] to these [ __ ] nerds
making robots next thing you know
there's going to be a knock at the door
and all of a sudden you're gonna be
looking right at yourself the robot
version you wear in the suit you wanted
and that things going to get it you're
going to give up your back it's going to
[ __ ] choke you out and no matter how
much you tap out those robots don't care
but this week my listeners can get any
premium indogene o suit for three
hundred and eighty nine dollars that's
right at indochina calm when entering
BRR at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price
for made to [ __ ] measure premium suit
389 bucks is not a premium suits a nice
suit that indochina doc that's Indochina
com promo code bur for any premium suit
for 3 and $89 and free shipping
incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could yeah 3 and 89 bucks actually
for a [ __ ] fitted suit is going to be
great you can walk into an Applebee's
and every chicken there's gonna think
you're a banker you got to do it next
thing you know right you're [ __ ] you
know you're ramming away trying to block
up the smell of that bloomin onion that
she's been carrying around all day
alright lift everybody you know about
lift right it's the app that gets you a
ride in minutes on-demand 24/7 for less
than the cost of a cab every lyft driver
is fully vetted through their ten-point
safety standard including criminal and
DMV background checks unlike those other
people with that other thing
that rhymes with müber all right you
don't know what you're gonna get right
you could walk in there with a bloody
axe those [ __ ] [ __ ] would hire you
you know you'll get around quickly and
safety with with lifts lifts drivers are
rated after every ride so only the best
stick around you don't have to worry
about getting into a filthy car with
some creepy dude everybody doesn't get a
ribbon at lift the way they do over it
mover with lifts you can tip in the app
which obviously leads to happier drivers
I mean not a tenth lifts riders get a
perfect five-star rating from the
passenger it's just a better way all
better all-around experience bigger
isn't always better lift isn't the
biggest ride-sharing app but it is the
fastest-growing and is rated one I'm
talking quality over quantity thanks to
lifts you can get it's an easy way to
avoid drunk driving you never have to
bum a ride but what if you're on heroin
it's another way to to avoid nodding off
in public hey now you're in the cab
nobody knows and you know what a lot of
people are actually getting rid of their
cars and relying on lyft to get around
and evidently I don't blame them what do
you do in the apocalypse when the
zombies come you think you can [ __ ]
call lift that lyft drivers getting the
[ __ ] out of here right now lyft is
offering our listeners a special deal
get three rides up to ten dollars each
that's a $30 value in case you can't do
basic math when you enter promo code
bill burr just download the free lyft
app today and then to the promo code
bill burr in the payment section you'll
start with three free rides up to $10
each that's up to a $30 value that's
promo code bill burr B I ll be URR no
space all caps alright how many more of
these [ __ ] things oh Jesus oh but
these are quick these are quick let me
tell you something Dollar Shave Club up
side and simply safe they respect the
fact that I'm not good at reading out
loud so these are three quick paragraphs
here we go
run in the table just like the Celtics
on the Bulls second Rondo sat down Bam
Bam Bam
three two two Celtics re Dollar Shave
Club is the smarter choice you'll get a
great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door you do you no longer have to schlep
to the store to buy a cheap disposable
razor razor that gives you a cheap shave
or
spend a fortune on raises with gimmicky
shaving tech you don't need and when you
use Dollar Shave club's an executive
razor with the executive razor comes
with the date-rape drug in the [ __ ]
handle some creepy banker walking around
his gold tote sucks shaping his nuts now
that's not what you do that's a
different read sorry
the Dollar Shave club's executive razor
with their doctor copies easy shape the
blade just gently glides giving you a
smooth shave dr. Kirby shea butter is
transparent for a more precise shave
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps make the smart choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time new members can get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of their dr. caddy for only $5 with Free
Shipping and after that the razors are
just a few bucks a month there's no
hidden fees and no commitments cancel
anytime you want
join the club today at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / alright up side
just sounds like a date movie right you
want to go see up side the down side of
the up side you want to go see that
stars Tom Hanks Meg Ryan Hugh [ __ ]
let me get a hooker or whatever the [ __ ]
his name was who's that English guy used
to go with elizabeth berkley Thank You
Jackman he's the guy who has to eat a
whole chicken every day to become
Wolverine I don't remember
Hugh Grant Hugh Grant you ready you bet
you you ready getting a [ __ ] hooker
hey I never judge that guy you get a
hooker why why wouldn't you why wouldn't
you what else you gonna do what else you
gonna do what go home and make some
[ __ ] Jiffy Pop you [ __ ] Hugh Grant
you crushing it you're a [ __ ] movie
star in your own country you go across
the pond you know know who's kidding who
England is like moto moto three [ __ ]
America is MotoGP that's what you want
to have your hit movies you guys all
know it's true Christ you're all
stealing our blue jeans you all you're
yeah
ADIS but you love our culture isn't it
safe to say that I'm [ __ ] with the
actual emotions of [ __ ] jeans come
companions all right up side there's a
better way for you to buy business
travel
it's called upside comm every time you
buy a trip it upside you'll save your
company a ton of money and they give you
an Amazon card with hundreds of dollars
upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and hotels together
for one low price that's what they do
they rip the seats out of a commercial
airliner and they just stuff you in
there you know you might think flying
standing up like you're at a mosh pit
for six hours from New York to LA might
suck yeah talk to me when you that only
cost you forty bucks no that's not what
they do
bundle pricing saves money this is what
they do if you're a frequent business
traveler your company saves a ton of
money and you can get thousands a year
in gift cards just for buying your air
and hotel together an upside you just
[ __ ] said this plus you still get
your miles dude what the feel like in
the end of this you're gonna be missing
a kidney this seems like to go to deal
and I get a gift card and I get to keep
my miles and I save them a bunch of
money if you're shopping for business
travel you'd be crazy not to check out
upside calm you're out of your mind
it just takes three minutes to see how
much you can save by buying your flights
and hotels together for one low price oh
I see they both cut side deals with each
other somebody's got to be doing you
know at some point somebody got sold in
the [ __ ] sex slavery here this is
just too good a deal and right now the
human trade right and right now when you
use my name bar you're guaranteed to get
at least a $100 Amazon gift card your
first trip that's my name burr to get at
least $100 Amazon gift card free say big
on travel and get a big gift card every
trip I love upside calm evidently upside
calm minimum purchase required see site
for complete details all right here's
the last one everybody it's simply safe
if you're not there when a fire starts
simply safe can be there to save your
home
1,000 say to [ __ ] throw you into it I
wasn't there but we'll put you right
back in it
it's kind of a good thing if you're not
there when the fire starts right simply
safe can be there to save your home all
right this is a robot that has a fire
extinguisher what is this with simply
safe home security you'll get a 24/7
connection to dispatch and lightning
fast responses times in emergencies all
right I have to look up dispatch what is
dispatch all I know is I've 24 [ __ ]
24-hour access to dispatch dispatch comm
that's not what I wanted that's not what
I wanted that's not what I wanted
don't you wish there was like voice
command on these things then you could
be to be like what did you want what did
you want for [ __ ] sakes it'll load
eventually I'll tell you what that means
later dispatch oh here it is
it is a send-off
[ __ ] Christ what just happened come on
now that's the load again send off to
destination or for a purpose deal with
the task the sending of someone or
something to a destination for a purpose
so they're going to send somebody who
has a purpose in life to your house when
it's on fire they're going to walk up
the street holding their [ __ ] head
high I'm imagining that person would you
know be driving a fire fire engine right
all right
the system is easy to use and completely
wireless you can install it yourself in
under an hour no installation guide
drilling holes in your walls no ugly
wires simply say founder and chief
engineer thought of everything when he
built this system backup batteries for
your base section station sorry a
cellular connection to the authorities
there are no long-term contracts no
commitments and no hidden fees simply
saves round-the-clock professional
security monitoring it's just $14.99 a
month order today and you'll get a
special 10% discount go to simply safe
bird com
that's si MP Li si Fe Burt calm for 10%
off your home security system hi simply
safe calm simply safe bird comm sorry
all right is that it is
I think I talked about everything right
yeah I believe I kid everything that I
want to talk but you know I was just
checking in on you here some [ __ ]
music excuse me that you guys can listen
to and we got another like half-hour of
stuff from classic podcasts from a
Thursday or a Monday and a year a day a
week gone by that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves I believe there's another f1
race this Sunday check it out if you can
let's go Celtics hoping for a classic I
hope he went but I also want to see
Rondo come up and do his thing too you
know what I mean cuz I still love that
guy he's still a Celtic to me alright
that's it have a great weekend you [ __ ]
and I'll talk to you on Monday
Ayya what the [ __ ] I'm talking about we
decided to have a [ __ ] party for a
new place you know you think that was my
idea
do you think it was my idea to have a
bunch of strangers coming to the [ __ ]
house I'll have people over that's what
I do
hey you want to come over and watch the
game nine people that I know right have
all your [ __ ] phone numbers you know
Nia is a more open person so she's like
let's have a party
all right so we chose invite your
friends so I'm all right so you know I
got you know I'm a guy I don't have a
bunch of friends okay I got six good
friends for that I could really trust
you know it's about it at least out here
Ben over here Nia talking to her mom
about all excited about the party and
she's like yeah I sent it out on foots
Facebook and I was just like oh my god
did I just invite a hundred and ten
people and my heart literally sank going
please tell me you didn't just invite
110 [ __ ] people she's like don't
worry they're not all gonna show up it's
like yeah but like a third will and then
they're gonna bring people that you
don't even [ __ ] know and that's
exactly what happened
it was a [ __ ] great party I'm not
gonna lie to you but I gotta admit like
I got to learn how to UM be I thought I
was gonna be a good host I was and I
wasn't I was all right with the people I
knew but the people I didn't know uh
actually most of them are alright but
there were a couple of them died just
fine I just said there's something
[ __ ] annoying about somebody you
don't know sitting on your goddamn couch
you know eating your food drinking your
booze like who the [ __ ] are you and
somebody else was laying down on the
floor I felt like the kid's dad wanna
get him get a [ __ ] job all right it's
over you're 26 you [ __ ] bum so anyway
so the party's going great and I'm
basically the whole time you know not
drinking too much but I'm standing by
the front door because that's the only
way out all right and nobody's walking
out with any of my [ __ ] right I'm acting
basically like psycho and [ __ ]
stripes how I am it's how I'm wired
all right so [ __ ]
three quarters way through the party
everything's going great now Mike well
this is yeah you know I forgot I forgot
I'm not 21 anymore I'm [ __ ] 43 all my
friends are adults and everybody's
drinking responsibly and no one's really
hammered nothing got broken everything's
cool so start just as I was starting to
relax some kid comes up to me he's like
yay dad you own the house and I'm like
well the bank owns it I'm [ __ ] paying
it off what can I do for you and he's
like yes kind of embarrassing but I used
the bathroom downstairs and it's clogged
now and I was wondering if he had a
plunger and I was like yeah I do have a
plunger I got a plunger right here the
upstairs bathroom so I give it to the
guy and I and I say man I appreciate
your honesty goes no problem he goes
downstairs he takes care of it comes
back he once again he goes he goes sorry
about that I said not at all not at all
what the [ __ ] it's a toilet
you know clogs up everyone's one but I
appreciate your honesty you know because
I would have been nasty good for you
right so uh another couple hours goes by
the party ends and there's like one
straggler left and I tell the story to
me I'm like you know I want to go what a
good guy what a good [ __ ] no pun
intended you know we could have left it
in there and then the other party I come
walking in my [ __ ] bathroom looks
like a goddamn Port Authority bus
station toilet you know so psyched so so
one of the stragglers at the party goes
yeah he goes I saw that whole thing go
down that's not exactly how it went down
I like what he talked about he goes he
goes it wasn't him
that was in the bathroom and I go who
was he because it was his girlfriend
[Laughter]
someone took a dump of a magnitude that
it wouldn't go down the toilet so now
she's in there panicking and this is
when today's technology kicks in she can
back in the day she would had to crawl
out the [ __ ] window and hope nobody
saw her and just left the door locked
everybody would have panicked holy [ __ ]
who's in there did somebody pass out is
somebody is somebody committing suicide
someone what it kicked in the door all
right
knock
off the [ __ ] goddamn hinges and you
go in there there'd be nobody in there
you'd feel the air from outside and then
look down and everyone would see a giant
[ __ ] and be like wow and the party would
be over and the owner of the house would
be walking around going oh you better
drive away right that's how would it
ended but because of today's technology
I'm not saying she didn't panic you know
it's even worse as a lady because
they're not even supposed to do stuff
like that right and she was able to text
her boyfriend and I would [ __ ] pay at
least four hundred dollars to read those
texts the panic in those texts and to
his credit he [ __ ] he eats he stepped
it up he took the hit he came up to me
vh1's I love the 80s own Bill burr and
said I took a dump in your toilet to a
magnitude it didn't go down and I need
the tools required to alleviate this
situation so anti douchebag of the week
that guy right there so taking a [ __ ]
bullet for the team that kid that right
there is the reverse Peyton Manning
award he didn't [ __ ] ago we had
protection issues right now he took one
he took one for the [ __ ] team went
upstairs like a goddamn gentleman asked
for a plunger gave it to him it was all
fun and I went down there at the end of
the party you never would have known
anything anything happened yet I mean
like you know three hours after the
Kennedy assassination I bet it was do
his own say it you know marked it all up
and everything was all figured out it
but it was a nice road again mopped up
pay we going on it's over and it is the
Monday morning podcast from Monday April
twenty-something 2009 I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is you know I really don't I
really don't all right I feel like [ __ ]
I had a really rough weekend in
Columbus Ohio but before I get into the
details I want to thank everyone who
came out on Friday Saturday and Sunday I
had a great time I had too good of a
time let's put it that way
um yeah too good a time too good a
[ __ ] time and I'm paying for it right
now
you know I don't know why I keep doing
this I don't know why I just can't learn
you know you know I always do overrated
underrated on this [ __ ] well you know
what's [ __ ] underrated eight hours
sleep you know you know what's you know
what's [ __ ] underrated going eh you
want another shot at Jameson you know
what no I think I've had enough you know
what I would like I would like a water
that's underrated you know not going to
[ __ ] Steak and Shake hit 3:00 in the
morning that's underrated get one of
those [ __ ] double burgers
I never even ate at that place before it
didn't even look like meat like a patty
you know what I've had he looks like
sure we all do we've all had a [ __ ]
burger even you little veggie [ __ ] out
there you know what it looks like
there's a little burned up wig and there
was two of them you know I was kind of a
40-year old [ __ ] guy gonna be 41 and
[ __ ] June goes to Steak and Shake at
3:00 in the [ __ ] morning when he's
got a goddamn [ __ ] h40 in the morning
flight why would you do that sure bill
you suck at math we all know that but
you can tell time I know there's numbers
involve of Jesus Christ what a [ __ ]
idiot
this whole [ __ ] day is it I just
started thinking about that Boogie
Nights I'm a [ __ ] idiot
I'm a [ __ ] idiot Eddie and I'm a
[ __ ] Eddie I'm a [ __ ] idiot
twice Friday night ended up at Steak and
Shake at 3:00 in the morning
you know [ __ ] Sunday night it was a
surprise I didn't walk in they weren't
like norm like on Cheers
here he is again all shit-faced Jesus
Christ what a [ __ ] motley crew you
want to see a motley crew go to a
[ __ ] steak and
shake at 3:00 in the [ __ ] morning
good God Almighty
now tell you I was part of the problem
oh you know I bet I was doing that
everything else was doing they all
sitting in there shit-faced looking
around everybody else going Jesus Christ
looking look at that [ __ ] guy oh my
God look at her
Jesus she wearing slippers Jesus Christ
you know you don't even realize they're
doing it to you - look at that [ __ ]
guy huh look at that look at his [ __ ]
eyes with them it's almost like he's
been drinking jameson all night why
wouldn't you get a water after a while
what a [ __ ] idiot
yeah let me have one your burnt up wig
[ __ ] burgers ah why is [ __ ] food so
good when you're when you're shit-faced
you know is that what it is shit-faced
[ __ ] food is just it's just all [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] decisions I didn't want to
do that man I was doing well you know I
went to Trader Joe's you know dodged a
bunch of [ __ ] Burgin stock hippies
and I you know I went in there like I I
oh I I got the fridge put in my room
[ __ ] global warming I want to be in
shape I had a fridge put my room I like
I had got all this healthy food what do
i do what do I do
I go out I go drinking two out of four
nights like a [ __ ] [ __ ] my god I
went to this one you know what I had a
bite a slice of pizza last night -
that's how [ __ ] up I was this is like
all coming it's like a slide show you
know you can't remember the [ __ ] that
happened in between but you just you
just have pictures good God Almighty was
that a bad-looking pizza
is there anything [ __ ] worse than
that just a bad looking it's just you
know this you know when someone makes a
pizza right and it even sucks when it's
hot but then it just sits there for a
while and it just gets that that cold
case file look to it you know what I
mean like it should have a [ __ ] toe
tag hanging off the crust they they
brought over a whole pie to look like
that you know it looked like some
five-year-old made it in like an
easy-bake oven you know and you're their
parent so now you have to eat it and say
oh wow Susie
it's delicious you know just begin begin
her little life of people lying to her
not being [ __ ] honest saying no don't
wear that you look fat in that now you
just go oh Susie you look beautiful
that's an excellent pizza you made you
want Susie it [ __ ] sucks all right
I'm not saying to give up your dream
about being a cook but you definitely
don't [ __ ] have any talent at this
point your life you know maybe we can
send you to some sort of oh Jesus Christ
what are those chef schools called huh
what is that art called you know come on
you know what it is because with a C
it's not custodial it's not Comus Eric
he plays for [ __ ] the Canadians Oh
Canadians I want to say bonjour to all
my friends up there in Montreal you know
it's just breaking your balls I've been
blogging for the Bruins and is basically
I went down was blogging for the Bruins
during the playoffs which I'm going to
continue to do because they swept the
Montreal Canadiens um and basically uh
you know I have to blog for the Bruins
of playing the Canadiens I mean what am
I going to say the Canadiens won 24 cups
we've only won five we haven't won since
1972 all I can do is just try to piss
you off that's all I was doing
the Montreal fans got really really
[ __ ] mad you know I made fun of their
coach I just did what I you know I just
made fun all they looked how they boo
their [ __ ] players I don't anymore
they said I was just trying to be a jerk
and people got all got his noisy well
hockey you know this guy calls himself a
comedian I don't think this is very
funny whatever you know it's [ __ ]
funny
I heard Celine Dion is thinking about
buying the Montreal Canadiens he's
probably moving to Vegas be a [ __ ]
mascot on ice that would be that would
be a crime that would be a goddamn crime
alright this is the Monday morning
podcast this is the hungover episode of
the Monday morning podcast I am sitting
in a hotel in Manhattan New York
why are you doing that bill huh you
laying low after your weekend of boozing
now I got a week at Caroline's
and I'm working with Joe DeRosa once
again my partner in crime too
codependent [ __ ] alcoholics do you
know one time I think I might have told
this story on ona Opie and Anthony show
for you uh people who live in I don't
know [ __ ] North Dakota um I don't
want that I was in Caroline's Caroline's
comedy club on Broadway where I will be
Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday for
a [ __ ] 22 shows 22 [ __ ] shows I
can't even do one show at this point I'm
laying low man I'm laying low um but
anyways one night I was I was standing
there at the bar and I decided I didn't
know if I decided I wasn't gonna drink
but I just wasn't drinking you know and
all of a sudden who comes walking down
the stairs you know like some starlet in
the 1950s making a big [ __ ] debut Joe
DeRosa nothing was missing was the
[ __ ] the evening gown he comes
[ __ ] Walse and down the stairs you
know all dainty like and the second I
saw him I was like half [ __ ] now I got a
drink right and you know what he was
thinking the exact same thing that was a
funny thing neither one of us wanted to
drink you got any friends like that you
just you just been fuck-ups for so long
that neither one of you can just pull
you out of the tailspin I'm sure anybody
was in a a good tell me what what
exactly that that's called what kind of
friendship that is um I don't [ __ ]
know I I really I really really feel
like [ __ ] right now and so I'm sitting
in the room and you notice the quality
might be a little bit better I actually
got a microphone now and I have a little
mixer and I have my headphones on and
I'm sitting here in the [ __ ] dark
that's not true I got the one little
desk light on basically talking to
myself you know technically once you
start listening this whole thing makes
sense but right now before I upload this
thing this is really uh you know this is
why they don't give everybody handguns
cuz if one was laying around I'm [ __ ]
with you you know what I would do I'd
probably pointed out the window I
wouldn't shoot anybody just try to scare
someone maybe make me laugh and I could
get
oxygen or something into my [ __ ] head
what you guys what are you guys use for
hangovers huh other than the smart thing
not drink anymore goddamn it's just so
much fun though you know I was having a
great time you know those broads you
know just having a good [ __ ] time
just a good time you know other [ __ ]
people who like to drink I met a couple
of hunters I've had a couple of dancers
I met you know I met her you know nice
mix of people that I'm a [ __ ] weird
dude man I don't like people before I
get on stage I don't want to see him I
don't see anybody in the [ __ ] crowd
but the second the show's over if
somebody's cool
III that's the part of the show I enjoy
and I become like this [ __ ] Charlie
Rose and I just started interviewing
people you know what's it like to shoot
a pheasant in the face huh what's that
like you know do you got a little
[ __ ] a couple of pieces of wood that
you rub together and somehow it sounds
like a pheasant going eh Eddie come on
over here you know or whatever [ __ ]
pheasants names are if you had a pet
pheasant what would you name it huh
Larry that'd be a great name for a
pheasant that's be funny if you had it
right people looking at it
oh my god is it a pheasant like Larry
get the [ __ ] off of that thing actually
got off of it you know and then you got
on a late-night talk show then you went
out there and then it didn't work and
then the host sort of mugged about how
it didn't work and then maybe takes a
turd on his [ __ ] wingtip shoe and
fifty years later it's part of the
greatest hits DVD you know and little
did you know that that was a pinnacle
your life as a [ __ ] zookeeper that
one moment you thought it was going to
keep happening nope
one episode one Episode you never asked
back because your animal [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] host shoe wasn't supposed to do
that it didn't do it they didn't do it
in the rehearsals all right how the [ __ ]
am I gonna maneuver this here all the
rattling in the background I got to move
my mixer are you know I feel right now I
feel like the [ __ ] Unabomber
all this goddamn was he anti-technology
though I don't know if he was anti or
pro at all I know he was definitely
[ __ ] alone and was a paranoid son of
a [ __ ]
my back
there we go you guys get nervous there
for a second
what the [ __ ] there's too many [ __ ]
cords here I'm gonna go back to this
cell phone I'm not holding my [ __ ]
laptop like a goddamn you know you know
it's servants used to hand [ __ ] to kings
would they put something on a pillow and
then they had their little hands
underneath it that's the way I'm holding
it I'll tell you what can I paint a
[ __ ] picture can I paint a goddamn
picture let me let me adjust the
microphone I want to tell you about my
microphone by the way do you remember
back in the 1970s you know nowadays
whenever somebody has a mic and they
have like a little filter or not a
filter whatever I don't know the techno
you know little spongy thing that you
stick on there so it doesn't pop or if
there's some sort of wind you know
nowadays they're just black and it just
looks like a you know [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
just sitting there right something that
they can put on TV you know but back in
the day man the 70s you know when people
were buying we'd buy the [ __ ] garbage
bag full and uh you know the 70s were
colorful man your [ __ ] day just
started off you know they had that crazy
serial that they used to have somebody
brought a boo berry or Count Chocula and
Frankenberry and I was in the cereal
aisle you know the other day when I when
I went to Trader Joe's when I was gonna
have a healthy week before I down five
bottles of whiskey
I'm the worst drunk too I'm one of those
guys I [ __ ] call up people and start
telling them I love them you know one of
those guys you know III do everything
but end up in the drunk tank on the
[ __ ] Andy Griffith Show I'm such an
old school drunk but I'm not an angry
guy when I get drunk I'm really not I'm
actually pleasant and I'm able to a
Moute is that why you do it bill I don't
[ __ ] know all I know is it makes me
feel like [ __ ] the [ __ ] was I just
talking about oh how cold color for the
70s were ya you'd start off with that
[ __ ] cereal that they had and was one
of the worst sentences ever yeah he
started off with that cereal that they
had oh there you go bill it's a great
way to [ __ ]
started off right if you pat yourself on
the back about how you could paint a
visual you know it's funny I have
headphones on right now I have no idea
how loud I'm talking and I'm sure that
there is somebody on the other side of
this wall
that is contemplating calling the front
desk but what they're listening to is so
[ __ ] bizarre they haven't been able
to tap out yet um well that's arrogant
bill maybe they're listening in your
sound [ __ ] annoying alright whatever
stop heckling yourself get to the point
yeah you start off with you eat tricks
you need boo bury the [ __ ] literally
changed the color of milk which is some
really hacky comedy from [ __ ] the 80s
but I'm telling you you had that [ __ ]
going on Honeycomb
you know the color [ __ ] people were
wearing polyester I mean [ __ ] was loud
in the 70s you know those plaid slacks
we like slacks he had boots that set up
the side they were all [ __ ] shiny
women had like those those plastic
looking purses it was [ __ ] freaky was
weird everything was like done suddenly
I think that the advertisers just like
look everybody's on drugs so we we
really need to enhance their trip so
much [ __ ] in the 70s was like really
done too even like the [ __ ] monkeys
which I guess you know was that this
that was the late 60s I think it went to
the early 70s when they used to [ __ ]
you know pretend to sing and pretend to
play instruments at the end of the show
there and they would they would cut to
their little musical montages and they'd
always do like half the time they would
do like those they'd put it like a
kaleidoscope so you had them actually in
the middle and then like six of them
like going around like a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] revolver so I don't know what it
was and you're eating that cereal you
just watching the [ __ ] anyways this all
comes around to my microphone back then
you can even watch like a sports show
without sort of tripping you know what I
mean like they had ABC's Wide World of
Sports and they had these [ __ ] bright
yellow sport coats on and I used to have
these microphones and when they stood
outside the little spongy thing that
they stuck on top wasn't black it didn't
blend in with the microphone there were
these crazy colors and one that I always
remember was there was always like
bright orange
it made no [ __ ] sense but as a kid I
liked it so whatever I bought a
microphone and the guy goes what kind of
windscreen do you want you know you want
the standard black one I said [ __ ] that
I want that one Keith Jackson used to
use when he do Monday Night Football way
back in the day or we do the college
games remember Keith Jackson huh hello
again everybody this is Keith Jackson
remember that guy Alabama Crimson Tide
and [ __ ] Wolverines at Michigan
they're gonna be swapping paint um
anyways yeah so that's what I got here
that was a really long [ __ ] way to go
to explain that I put an orange spongy
thing on the end of my [ __ ] mic and
I'm a Jew I know I'm cursing a lot right
now and I'm cursing I'm not cursing at
you guys okay sometimes people get
confused stop cursing at me I'm not
cursing you I'm cursing at my hangover
as I described [ __ ] to you all right
Jesus Christ look at this [ __ ] fake
wood in this desk this is the kind of
desk that you sit you know that you sit
at when you're like confessing to a
murder you know what I mean you just
sitting in there trying to wear you down
they bring in some food acting like
they're your friends I was just watching
those [ __ ] cold-case files Mac
goddamn those things are creepy just
[ __ ] creepy just watching the people
when they come in and they and they and
they they get in question for the murder
and they just sound like you know
regular regular guys where were you that
night
ah you know was home yeah watching a
basketball game you know you're chilling
out at a P to find out he [ __ ] hacks
up 23 people then when they won then
when they admit it they're like oh yeah
yeah I did it you know they found this
one guy that that who's that [ __ ] guy
that the Green River I always got to
give him Nick names the [ __ ] news so
they can sell more papers they give him
nicknames like they're going to the Rose
Bowl or some [ __ ] you know Crazy Legs
Johnson he's killed 48 [ __ ] people
they call him the Iceman um anyways so
there's one guy up in Seattle right he
killed all these all these women was
brutal
and they picked the guy up he'd never
been arrested before they they meet him
outside of his job because they put
together a case okay he has no idea that
they're on to him and they got they the
cops come up to the guy and they say
listen buddy we're you know [ __ ]
whatever the police officers I choose to
I got a headache I don't want the [ __ ]
they say you know they say hi we're cops
and we're here to arrest you for the
murder of four women now if you never
been arrested before when your heart
drop the guy just is like he I evidently
he just went okay then they brought him
down there he confessed to that and he
confessed to like [ __ ] sixty other
women that he had killed so they bring
this guy into another room to talk to it
to a psychologist you know because he
wants to try to break him down so he can
figure out she can stop these maniacs
right and they asked the guy this
question they said you know if you could
um if you could pick out one thing about
your personality that you feel is
different from the average person
walking down the street what would that
be and without missing a beat the guy
said that that whole caring thing Wow
you know when you think you don't give a
[ __ ] Jesus Christ just rag off yeah the
whole Karen that old Carrington yeah I
just don't seem to give a [ __ ] it's
weird you know I don't know I hate
watching it I don't know why I watch
that she'll it show literally gives me
nightmares you know what I mean you
start thinking about the pit what this
is not funny what the [ __ ] am I talking
about see this is what happens this is
what happens when you go out boozing you
know what the sad thing is is I know at
some point at some point this weekend
I'm probably gonna do this again but
fortunately I'm in New York City so I
won't end up at a Steak and Shake I've
never eaten there I think I've made fun
of that [ __ ] place on these podcast
how would you rate how would you guys
out there huh all my listeners out there
please tell me you listen and please
tell me I'm not I'm not just sitting
here baking under this [ __ ] hotel
lamp for nothing how would you
right the worst your worst like
fast-food you know what I mean everybody
you know no one wants to eat it but we
all need it cuz you know tastes good
[ __ ] tastes good but then this does
certain ones either you had either you
had a bad experience or you just the
look of it you know like I say for me
like Taco Bell I just can't go in there
there's just something about the colors
on the sign it just makes my stomach
hurt you know you get that awful feeling
in your stomach you know I feel the same
way about like Arby's he's never [ __ ]
with the Arby's I'm a McDonald's guy I'm
old-school like McDonald's in and out of
this [ __ ] but you know I got a lot of
memories as a kid at McDonald's so I
think that one still wins even though in
and out is even better but there's just
certain ones I won't even go into you
know all right guys I'm [ __ ] fading
fast Jesus Christ I need a [ __ ] water
or something the hell did I do with that
water didn't I have water around here
hang on a second Jesus Christ [ __ ]
water I should had last night all right
let's get on with the questions here um
if you're new to my page you probably
think I'm out of my [ __ ] mind and you
would be right I am out of my mind but
you know what you know what I don't have
anything to say to that I am guilty as
charged
what are you [ __ ] perfect why don't
you go to [ __ ] wwm [ __ ] perfect
calm and go listen to that podcast I bet
there's a lot of [ __ ] laughs on that
one you know do they got a mixer I got a
[ __ ] mixer [ __ ] you like that [ __ ]
I'm learning a lot of computer stuff you
know what how about you guys make me
computer literate can you do that for me
I'll start off with something really
easy something that really [ __ ]
annoys me on my computer and you know
what maybe someone else does this is
maybe this annoys someone else who has a
computer who also has a drinking problem
okay
and then you know I'll read how to do it
I mean I can help so another drunk out
there all right this is one of my
problems that I have when I go to you
when I go into Apple works right the
text is so [ __ ] small I don't
understand it it's set
I know how to change it but I got to
change it every time all right right now
it's stuck on 12 okay which is basically
squinch size and you know when I copy
and paste you guys emails into my
[ __ ] thing it's it makes it smaller I
don't know what it's doing
I want it at 18 I want the default set
at 18 how the [ __ ] do I do that in Apple
works I got a brand new MacBook I want
to learn how to do that okay I want to
learn some [ __ ] you know I know how to
upload I know how to do this now look at
me I know how to upload [ __ ] I'll turn
it into a [ __ ] mp3 I'll send it right
to you I know how to do that now I feel
great
it's my new opening line when I hit on
chicks on the road you know what's up
sweetie are you doing you like the show
you know I can also upload audio files
and turn them into an mp3 huh put it on
the desktop
I'll [ __ ] drag it right over there
same way I'm gonna drag you across the
[ __ ] carpet in my hotel what the [ __ ]
was that all right
can somebody teach me how to do that
please okay and let's get on with the
podcast too you know what the problem is
is this not enough [ __ ] room here I
got it why don't I just move this dude I
even have a little stand here from my
microphone I have a little [ __ ] stand
this is like I don't know this is one of
these like really nerdy things that if
you start when you're 18 by the time
you're 30 you're famous and you're not a
nerd anymore like chicks want to [ __ ]
you it's um it's unreal but when you
start this at 40 it's just pathetic and
said okay here we go we're gonna go to
uh I already did the underrated so why
don't I do over it um I know this is
really this is really coming off grumpy
I understand but whatever you know last
week I was pissed
this week I'm grumpy you know what I'm
due for a happy one how about next week
next week I'll be all bubbly no I won't
because I'll be flying across this
country ah man that's gonna suck let's
not think about that do you know like I
literally fall asleep on the plane I've
flown across this country so many
[ __ ] times that I can literally look
down and
pretty much guess what state I'm over
you know as a passenger I can do that
why these levels so low but the [ __ ] is
going on there we go am I not talking
into this thing hello test there we go
you know I mean I can look out I can
tell you know pretty good I mean Rick I
don't know wait a minute what the [ __ ]
am i bragging about when Southwest is a
desert you get into Colorado you got the
mountains starts getting flat you're
like RI this is Nebraska Kansas
maybe we're into Iowa you start seeing
more lights you're moving towards
[ __ ] into Illinois right that how it
works I don't [ __ ] know like I
actually like I recognize like lakes now
you know I can look down on my watch wow
you know what it's taking this long
we're right about here yeah we should be
seeing Cleveland coming by there it is
there it is
I look down some time to look at [ __ ]
stadiums fill my [ __ ] life is now if
I could be outside the plane and look at
my stupid round head looking out of that
little oval [ __ ] window this is what
I signed up for this is how [ __ ]
hungover I am I'm actually bitching that
I'm a comedian something that I wanted
to do something that I decided to do
alright Jesus Christ there was a way for
you guys to email me a [ __ ] tampon I
I think I get like 9 million this week
alright ah here we go let's read the
overrated alright let's get into your
thoughts I think you've heard enough
from me for one week alright overrated
bill alright bill I think this is
overrated a lot of people don't talk
about this this is coming from a woman
she says male strippers are overrated
she said especially when they are hired
for a bachelorette party is it me or
does uh Jesus Christ I can't read when
I'm [ __ ] not hungover she goes isn't
me or does anyone else think this is the
stupidest waste of 125 bucks they've
ever seen you guys get strippers 125
bucks Jesus is there anything that sucks
about being a woman yeah
giving birth periods all right you're
right you're right sorry um yeah okay
team as we get back to this yeah the
guys are all the guys were all muscled
up and everything but to be honest when
you see women looking at male strippers
and they are hooting and hollering and
laughing and laughing it up with their
girlfriends they're actually laughing at
the stripper yes it is true that they
are likely some women who enjoy it and
thinking this guy would probably be
awesome in bed but 95% of women are
hysterically laughing at the ridiculous
man all oiled up in his g-string with
his stupid little boom box playing in
excess what you need Jesus Christ yet
she just there you go she's painting a
picture there that's what you need a
good story and you need a narrator he's
not [ __ ] grumpy and hungover
anyways playing what you need gyrating
around the living room and dry humping
dad's lazy boy you know what Jesus
Christ
ahh bla bla bla bla bla this is really
[ __ ] long let me get to the point
here she says women what women want is
women want a man who was a man kill
spiders drink beer etc none of us would
picture our man acting like a sex
machine with a wax chest dancing in
front of a group of housewives a man
will offer my girlf man will offer my
girlfriend is a stripper and he knows
his buddies will congratulate him like I
do would you go find a stripper that's
awesome a woman would never offer the
same information why because she knows
the response her mother woman would be a
snicker and a yikes gee I'm so sorry
look is that true the women really not
like don't just like Cougars don't they
like male strippers you know if you want
to know what it's like to be a guy be a
woman in your feet as far as like our
sex drive you know I think maybe a woman
once you're in your 40s or that
demanding what the [ __ ] point I'm trying
to make there I just know that like
older women act like the same level of
[ __ ] that guys act like it our
entire [ __ ] lives when they start to
get older I don't know what it is I
guess it's safe they finally don't give
a [ __ ] and they could admit that they
like [ __ ] or they like sex you know
because before they have to be like well
you know it's just for procreation
all right just like my boyfriend's [ __ ]
I don't have any other [ __ ] fantasies
you know
where's guys we just get we just get to
be pigs we just get to be the goddamn
pigs that we are but you know what you
get to cry at movies and get that [ __ ]
out I gotta hold it in
you know what that was a rough one was
that Harvey Milk movie the amount of
[ __ ] I had to think about so I wouldn't
tear up during that movie just so I
wouldn't be feel you know as a guy you
can't [ __ ] cry so I gotta sit there
Billy you know as he's going through
some [ __ ] I know everyone was getting
all sad when uh you know when he gets
whacked there you know so in order not
to get emotional myself I just thought
you know what if someone just came home
and just kicked him right in the balls
and I just start laughing you know
that's what it is
that's what comedy is it's to stop from
crying alright um number two oh this is
Shaw oh my god this so New Yorkers
aren't gonna like this one
this is another thing that she says is
overrated is underrated actually a
two-run homer in the bottom of the ninth
ninth after Murray off of Mariano Rivera
and I could have [ __ ] read that
better
yeah the Red Sox swept the Yankees man
it's [ __ ] unbelievable
they'll be back this [ __ ] always happens
one team always jumps out in front of
the other team right and then we do we
[ __ ] own you guys we [ __ ] own you
guys and then they literally almost like
it's fixed now the Yankees will sweep us
down there and we'll play each other
like 12 times or 13 times and someone
will win that win it [ __ ] seven to
six it's a goddamned business people
okay
there's no [ __ ] Santa Claus I don't
buy it um and we stole home plate no how
the [ __ ] does that happen two hundred
million dollar team you know something
you realize the Red Sox sale they're
only their number four this year as far
as money spent oh yeah a lot of you
[ __ ] didn't know that did you
Yankee spent 200 million then it's the
Mets then I believe the Cubs and then US
122 million is that great now we can act
like we're some little [ __ ] starving
panty little pansy [ __ ] team Yankees
a ruin in baseball
um who gives a [ __ ] I say what's funny
is of the the [ __ ] did I just do there
mess it on my computer all right let's
play you know I'm really starting to
feel like I'm losing the momentum of
this 31 minutes 31 hungover minutes dude
I'm gonna tell you right now this is
stealing like four hours I feel like I'm
doing a [ __ ] telethon right now ah
let's get to the questions for the week
I got a I got one here um am I the only
one who thinks Terry Francona's glasses
make him look like a cancer stricken
mrs. Claus he's the Kezia he's the
manager of the Red Sox I did Sam yeah
those they they're definitely yeah he
looks like he should be at the very
least you know going out caroling or
something reading the night before
Christmas I don't [ __ ] know I don't
know you know I talked a lot about
sports last week and a couple people
really got pissed just talking about how
dumb they are some guy sense this this
huge [ __ ] rant about saying how you
know being into a sports team is almost
as dumb as patriotism I know the point
you're trying to make you know what I
mean I get it you know
I know what you're saying but you know
what the [ __ ] dude I mean I got done
like almost two years of these things
eventually sports was gonna come up we
always have to talk about what you want
to talk about this guy was really I
don't know sometimes I don't know if
people are going for douchebag of the
week I don't know what do I have
anything else here I don't think I've
anything else Oh bill I need some advice
all right here's another guy obviously
had some Jameson listen to this [ __ ]
this is his question hey Bill
big fan bombed right now I didn't get
that for a second a dud like he said big
fan and he meant like that line bomb but
evidently means he's shit-faced or he's
the worst speller anyway in the world
here we go
it starts off it says anyways I need
some objective viewpoint me and this hot
chick I'm a big ol ugly rugby player
recently started hanging out he
misspelled that and we like no e he put
the e at the beginning of each we like
each a lot
Jesus Christ dude recently started
hanging out we like each other a lot my
problem she used to date a black guy I
have black friends my buddies will tear
me apart thoughts advice thanks John
well John um my thoughts are you're
pretty [ __ ] shit-faced when you uh
when you sent that email that's my
thoughts cuz the rest of it makes no
sense used to date a black guy okay you
have black friends is that supposed to
establish that you're not racist my
buddies will tear me apart like what
they're gonna in a good-natured way rib
you that your dick isn't gonna be as big
I don't know what you're trying to say
here tell you what why don't you [ __ ]
you know don't email me now cuz I know
you're feeling the way I'm feeling but
you know sober up try to clean that up
you know I think maybe you got something
there send me a second draft I don't
know what the [ __ ] that means she used
to date a black guy how the [ __ ] would
they know you had black friends my buddy
will tell you you and your black friends
do they know this guy did she use to
date one of the one of your friends
who's black that's just a weird
statement I have black friends do you
have black friends sure we all do like
you're trying to loan yourself some sort
of credit credibility the [ __ ] does that
mean anyways you know how many friends
do I have Joe DeRosa he's half Egyptian
so that takes care of the does that take
care of Arabs or Egyptians considered
air I know what the [ __ ] Arabs are I
don't even know
I'll [ __ ] know okay you know I don't
know I don't is being innocent one
question I was is being Jewish is that
oh I know it's a religion is it or is it
a race it's not race right I don't want
to tell a long time ago I I was in high
school and one of my friends was Jewish
right and uh I said to him I said he
will you Italian he goes no I'm Jewish
and I could tell I offended him so I
didn't do a fall
have question but in my head I'm going
okay Italian is a race that that Jewish
was a religion I know Jewish is a
religion you know did that make any
[ __ ] sense I don't [ __ ] know let's
let's read a revenge story let's meet a
revenge story and let's [ __ ] wrap up
this podcast this is gonna be a shorter
one this is the hungover version always
something else I came up with is I'm
actually contributing under eighty you
know it's underrated free internet in
the hotels goddamn and I like that I
wrote all that other [ __ ] in anger so
let's not read that all right here's a
big long revenge story to end the
podcast this week and let me know got
what you guys think about this sound I
know kind of a turn in my head a little
bit I got this mic like stationaries
affecting the sound because God knows
I'm not going to go back and listen to
all this [ __ ] I usually listen to them
but not this week man not this week I've
been a rough [ __ ] week I don't want
to tell you you know this one these time
so it's great I don't have a kid you
know because I would have no patience
for him you know it's a new bit I've
been working on in my act talking about
how much I like I like kids when they're
I like kids the same way like I like
dogs I like I like them when they're
puppies and their full of life you know
once I get a little bit older and Stuber
and they think they know [ __ ] it's just
it's [ __ ] they're annoying you know I
like kids like you know what [ __ ]
cracks me up
I saw this kid the other day this kid
was like 2 years old right you know it's
funny about toddlers right how they did
I talked about this already
honey I got their little [ __ ] they
got their you have a beer belly and they
never even drank they look you know they
look these little [ __ ] truckers it
always is just [ __ ] makes me toddlers
[ __ ] beer bellies just [ __ ] make
me laugh every time I say oh you know
it's because they're not self-conscious
about their bodies they don't give a
[ __ ] so they just got it hanging out
there like some [ __ ] drunken slob at
a barbecue you know they just it's just
funny to me they look like they've
already fed they [ __ ] up in life you
know like they're gambling they're
eating the wrong food I don't know why
do they have those fat bellies Jesus
Christ you're eating mush in milk
you're the first Ana well I just admit I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about sometimes I'm literally sweating
right now because of a lamp that's how
[ __ ] hungover I am okay here we go
you know something else I hate I mean
this is something I've been doing I've
been I've been trying to eat you know
one just veggie meal a day you know so
then I can make up for the [ __ ] oxen
that I'm going to eat later on that
night or evidently the [ __ ] steak and
shake that I'm gonna eat and you know I
can't stand about those [ __ ] veggie
meals I ordered this veggie meal right I
ordered a UH some sort of [ __ ]
horrific veggie wrap which really sucked
cuz they grilled the vegetables you know
what like when you go beyond where they
start becoming mushy it just I can't
even say what it sounds like what if
what it tasted like because it's gonna
make me [ __ ] gag here but you know
it's just I'm gonna do it you know what
if you're squeamish cover your [ __ ]
ears right now you know what it tastes
like when you lay over steamed
vegetables or they [ __ ] over grill I
don't know what it gets all squishy and
mushy it tastes like it's pre-chewed
just pausing right now waiting for the
groans people throwing their headphones
off
all you people on elliptical talented
you just grown to the hat the fat hairy
[ __ ] next to you start looking at you
wondering what you listening to um this
is what I hate your order veggie wrap
all right they go one veggie wrap I
ordered some soup like an old [ __ ]
Jewish man in Manhattan right and then
what happens they bring it to me and
this they got french fries on the side
it's I can't you see I'm trying I'm
trying to get in shape I understand it's
a french fry it's a potato it's a
vegetable I get it what the [ __ ] it's
like when you go to the Cheesecake
Factory you order salad and then they go
would you like 2/3
it's like do you not get the [ __ ]
theme here lady do you not see what I'm
trying to do you see my bloated
alcohol-infused face
do you understand what I'm trying to do
here actually no it's not even fair
because I actually talked to one of
those uh cheesecake I think I was making
fun of the Cheesecake Factory and I act
and there actually was there was a
waitress in the crowd as always I always
end up [ __ ] on something and then
someone from the crowd is like hey I do
that what the [ __ ]
so it was his Cheesecake Factory
waitress and she came up to me and she
said uh she goes actually they make us
do that we have to do that if we don't
do it we get fired really is that what
it's come down to that's that's where
the decisions in your life led you that
you have a job that if you don't ask
people for cake which is usually a nice
[ __ ] thing to do if you don't do it
you get fired they have a gun to your
[ __ ] head to basically have your job
to try to make people become diabetics
is that what's going on is that what
happened in your life because you sucked
at something in school you know I don't
[ __ ] know all right let's get on with
the revenge story I am [ __ ] I know
why I shut off the air conditioners
anybody else just hate air conditioning
I don't mind air conditioning when it's
9,000 degrees out but when it's [ __ ]
you know it's like I don't know what it
is it's like 65 degrees out 70 72 and
they got the air conditioning on it's
like are you trying to give me pneumonia
huh as I went to [ __ ] you're trying to
do Jesus Christ am I in a mood hey what
do you guys think about that swine flu
you know this might be a little comfort
controversial but I'm kind of all for it
I think this is another time where where
we're getting in the way of nature
running its course nature is trying to
kill off us not all of us but some of us
so that you know there's no traffic you
know what I mean it's like the forest
fire it's a rebirth you know you burn it
down some animals die some trees die you
get rid of all the brush it's like a
spring cleaning that's all a plague is
it
that we you know you don't want any
loved ones to die plague them I'll tell
you meant plagues that they're a really
uh they're fascinating like they're
putting out all these stats you know it
[ __ ] this revenge story let me go on the
internet here let me let me uh let me
restart Firefox now what is your [ __ ]
problem I never stopped it I'm in the
middle of a podcast goddamn these
[ __ ] computers what do they do this
[ __ ] to me come on let's go
anyways yeah they were they were given
up all these uh all these statistics on
plagues and that type of stuff evidently
do you know like like six hundred and
seventy five thousand people died in the
United States in nineteen eighteen
because of like an i influenza whatever
the [ __ ] that is I know what the [ __ ]
that is but everybody got it and a whole
bunch of people died and you know what's
[ __ ] you know what's [ __ ] up about
that was thank God they did you know cuz
if they didn't they all would have
[ __ ] and they would have made more
[ __ ] P we might have been where we're
at right now we might have been them you
know fifteen years earlier although I
just throw numbers out man like I'm a
[ __ ] scientist here know what I'm
talking about
hang on a second let's look up plagues
it's gonna give me a some sort of FBI
list you know I need to do now is Google
[ __ ] anthrax and they'll be a knock
at my door and I really will be
confessing at this [ __ ] table here
great plagues in history okay this
should be a great game show
that's a be a [ __ ] great game show
okay is you tried it you start googling
[ __ ] and whoever gets the FBI to come to
your place first wins and you can't do
like easy [ __ ] like like obviously any
sort of creepy pedophile stuff because
that's just [ __ ] horrific it's it's
never funny is it even though I joke
about it on stage sometime all right
list of historical plagues let's go to
Wikipedia god knows they're always
number one
all right in human history the term
plague refers to an epidemic disease
causing a high rate of mortality a
pestilence an academic - shut the [ __ ]
up I want to I want stats okay what I
gotta go MLB gotta go to cbssports.com
so I got to go on going danger great
plagues of Athens let's get to some
recent ones here you know what do we got
here great plague of Iceland see you I'm
saying everywhere everybody had a plague
in it then the heard great plague of
Portugal great plague of Russia great
plague of Ireland Scotland London plague
just attacked a [ __ ] city for two
years 1592 - 1590 for the Italian plague
everybody's [ __ ] had one was last time
we had a plague you know you just say
that you just can nip it in the butt
with wit with [ __ ] with the media
they just they get it out there
before it gets a chance to to help with
the traffic you know so I'm in New York
City right now and they they have a
number of a number of cases out in
Queens and you know they're telling
people how oh you know it's funny how
they tell people did you use common
sense if you feel like you're getting
the flu go to the hospital right so they
say you know if you sneeze or if you
cough just cover your mouth right so
half hour later I'm walking down the
street walking down whatever [ __ ]
Avenue here in New York and I see this
kid on a bicycle and he proceeds to
sneeze and he just turns his head and it
looked like a [ __ ] spit take and I
just bursted out laughing bursted out
laughing you know rather than being I'm
like the exact opposite of a I was gonna
say a hemophiliac that's not what I'm
trying to say what are those [ __ ]
people that always nervous that they got
something a hysterectomy what is it I
know it begins with an H this always
happens to me it's what happens to my
[ __ ] brain as I knew the word and
then it might brain panics and all I'm
left with is a letter uh [ __ ]
hemophilia I can't get that word out of
my head
you know what I got to talk about
something else let's talk about the
Jonas Brothers comedy show huh I think I
speak for the group when I say it's
about time you know because their music
is [ __ ] hilarious and I I just you
know the [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] business you don't I mean
really is that what I should that's not
what I should have done I should have
gotten this business with [ __ ] three
and three of my other brothers you know
I'll play the drums you get a ukulele
and then you do this and then you'll get
your own [ __ ] sketch show sons of
[ __ ] oh yeah I am better I'm better
about the [ __ ] Jonas Brothers I want
some goddamn stats here on dead people
all right I don't feel good so I want to
read about dead people make all the
black death here we go here we go the
black death was one of the deadliest
pandemics the [ __ ] is a pandemic there's
an epidemic and a pandemic a pandemic is
an epidemic of infectious disease that
spreads through pop populations across
their large region for instance a
continent or even worldwide Thank You
Wikipedia so what the [ __ ] is an
epidemic is what happens and you just
start [ __ ] searching everything and
then you figure out what the hell an
epidemic occurs when new cases of a
certain disease occur in a given human
population during a given period it's
not the same [ __ ] thing is that not
the same [ __ ] thing
close enough all right you guys won't
hear about the Black Death huh when
you're sitting there in your cubicle at
work well goddamn it I'm gonna read you
some [ __ ] God knows you could do this
yourself it's right there in Wikipedia
the black death was according to
chronicles characterized by buboes a
swelling in the lymph nodes I don't even
know where the lymph nodes are I think
there are they in your neck a
hypochondriac BAM I got it all right see
that's what I got to do just start
talking about all this [ __ ] then I don't
know where I yell out the word and now I
can't remember what I was talking about
all I know I'm the exact opposite of a
high
Kadri acquara now that doesn't make
sense hypochondriac is nervous not to
keep my ID apples scientists and
historians at the beginning of the 20th
century assumed that the black death was
an outbreak of the same disease caused
by the bacterium who gives a [ __ ] and
spread by fleas with the help of of
animals like the black rat however this
view has recently been give me some
stats for Christ's sake how many [ __ ]
people died what wait wait a minute the
origins of the plague is entered at Deb
Dibby Dibby do the total number of
deaths worldwide is estimated at 75
million people approximately 25 to 50
million of which occurred in Europe the
Black Death is estimated to have killed
30% to 60% of Europe's population just
think about that people 6 out of 10
automobiles that you'll see in front of
you tonight as you try and drive home
would not [ __ ] be there and we
already built the highways to hold you
know a ton of [ __ ] car you know what
I'm saying you know it's America man you
want to [ __ ] drive put the top down
then I'm making Pontiacs anymore how
[ __ ] sad is that let's think about
some great Pontiacs
that's where we're gonna close out after
we talked about the epidemic we talked
about death let's talk about how sad it
is that there's no more Pontiacs anymore
there's just no more the Pontiac
trans-am huh
kind of drops off after that but you
know the Sunbird the t1000 you guys
remember the Pontiac t1000 that's when
you're really [ __ ] up when you bought
a bootleg Chevette that's when you
really was saying that you were an extra
level of white trash okay you ate
macaroni and cheese five times a [ __ ]
week you know
you know I can't know what the [ __ ] I've
sivan said today that was I riffing
about sharing a tray of macaroni cheese
with another man looking into his eyes
was that this podcast was that another
podcast was that's at some point is show
last night I don't know what but it's
been the Monday morning podcast for uh
April [ __ ] twenty something I don't
know what it is I don't know this is
we're in the garbage time they still
have their as well their official site
is still up when I want to Pontiac so
they have the Bonneville you know what
they were a one-trick pony anybody drive
a Pontiac I don't know what let's talk
about that next week okay this is the
Monday morning podcast I'd be a
Caroline's this week and then I'm taking
a break here for May and June gonna
recharge my [ __ ] batteries and coming
out swinging in July start at the Comedy
Works in Denver and then I go to Eddie's
fist-fuck in [ __ ] Yuma I'm just going
to make up [ __ ] now and then I'm going
to be at wallpaper Freddy's at the
limelight beautiful theater where Cirque
du Soleil performed just reading the
awful brochures here what is Cirque de
Soleil I'm really impressed with the
strength that those guys have not so
much on the costumes alright you guys
that's the podcast for this week I hope
you guys all have a tremendous week and
I apologize if I was a little bit grumpy
this week but uh you know I'm sorry
alright
that's something I'm just going to palm
sorry alright